[Music]
[Applause]
what is up people of America and the
world
we're here because we care we're here
because we're better than most folks
hell yeah brother harder more insightful
and uh frankly we're also right yeah
that's why you should be watching hell
yeah I'm here to raise hell and praise
Dale baby domestic terrorists
speaking of domestic terrorists I mean I
want to jump right into making a
domestic terrorism what did you do on
the weekend what did I do on the weekend
wait what did I do oh speaking of the
best of terrorists I was going to say a
brave domestic terrorist Warrior was
taken out by the unjustifiable FBI
yesterday did you hear about this guy in
Provo Utah oh
we just Dove right into it we got to do
our head I'll pull it up no no let's do
our let's do our intro let's do it you
know I got really excited I'm excited
now I love domestic Terror well should I
well you want to go shopping really fast
are you sure let's go shopping first and
then we'll we'll everybody's favorite
segment uh Hassan picks whatever he
wants from Teddy fresh for all we're all
the where all the plebs cry at home
a lot so I'm happy to say finally got a
new bag man this bag or this is the new
bag that's pretty what happened
so they can't see me or they can't see
my monitor
this is my old bag I've been using this
for like three years it is literally
disintegrating
and so I'm happy we got it I love that
bag thank you
so here you could tell me yes let's fill
that bag up Persona are they ready
all right everybody
let's go yes so um obviously as we wait
for this uh the xqc debate happened on
yesterday right yeah yesterday was that
yes no I was like two days ago oh it was
so good I chair reacted to it it was
fire
I watched I watched uh your reaction a a
fair bit of it and there was there was a
point where I had moments where you were
mad at me I wasn't mad but I was
strongly disagreeing with you yeah and
potentially
I do want to talk about it but I'm gonna
be very nice
I promise you guys watching aren't gonna
get mad at me this time I think people
need to understand first of all maybe my
brain is broken because of like all the
people that I am used to debating
including xqc uh that like normally
debates are all like a like a three hour
intense three hour three V one where
like people are basically [__] slinging
towards me and just like conversations
have unwinded from the main point of
contention uh so that's why like when
you and I had that conversation I was
like what do you mean this is very
cordial and then everyone was like no I
got terrible leftovers is over it's just
like in front of me well yeah that's
silly that's like I was like what even
you apologizing for it was I think
ridiculous you did well you didn't go it
that hard
I think I
I don't know I could I think I think
personally I could have been a little
bit
listen this is a deep heartfelt apology
I'm so used to being interrupted I just
thought that your interruptions were
normal like it wasn't even like a crazy
amount
well anyway today's gonna be different
okay but but hopefully but unless you
disagree then there's gonna be an issue
dude holy Mo we're gonna we're gonna
duke it out dude all right so here we go
the color block 2.0 is back if anybody's
looking
uh this is the vintage inspired denim
bomber this is the most ADHD we've ever
been in the beginning of this broadcast
I love the soccer mom one God damn it
it's for women isn't it uh well hold on
let me check Countryside button up
t-shirt 12 bucket hat
safety pin cardigan Patchwork crochet
lace button up shirt
no not your Vibes not a lot of this is
my vibes except for the soccer mom one
and that that looks sick it's a it's a
unisex it's a rugby one yeah with that
triple XL baby all right sweet there it
is it's another green one though that I
can't wear on the broadcast here right
that sucks that's like one of the
reasons
even this shirt I was like man [__] it
I'm wearing this [__] and but it's a
little green this is a vintage Mini
duffel bag looks pretty sick whoa whoa
that is sick
you want it oh what the [__] what oh
it's coming soon you want a bag go ahead
uh I don't want to take away did people
want it you want to fill this bag up
there's a there's a there's a Teddy
first lover out there who's gonna who's
gonna want that also I'm proud to
announce that
it is
I saw that it had the
okay
never mind they have the sticker here an
announcement they have the sticker that
says I'm recycled but I don't see any
details in the description color block
cardigan picnic bear T this is the one
I'm wearing yeah
okay never mind yeah we got two I
ordered this one yesterday no I want the
one that the one that you're wearing
pastel one okay you influenced me there
it is we got this you want matching
shorts or is that doing too much no
that's too much yeah
we have the dolphin tea we've got this
classic iconic uh a crew neck
bucket hats
Terry bucket hats dude I have too many
bucket hats mostly from long sleeves
checked out crochet sweater
Terry bear Polo
checkered tea these are real nice
uh here's the Corduroy uh carry bag
messenger bag color block corduroy
jacket I need a bag that's like big
enough for my steam deck that's what I
need but like not so big I don't think
steam deck fits in that yeah it wouldn't
maybe the mini duffel bag would uh Terry
bear zip up bomber jacket this thing's
sick
but you know
and then we got the of course the two
Ted socks this is a crowd favorite
uh oh that's cute yeah people love these
it was a two-tone corduroy shorts yeah
peek over there let me see what yeah
let's see what's up there oh these are
like super long too they're I mean
that's popping right now that's very in
it's very fashionable maybe I should
grab a pair of these like very long
shorts very big shorts by flipper
everybody's wearing big shorts and and
tiny ass uh skin tight
uh White beaters okay that's a that
seems like a crazy look just here that
is that's the look man in New York
uh we've got this uh Not Your Bear uh I
have one of those yeah not that specific
one but I already have one in the
numbers we got black Ted socks we have a
rugby stripe polo dress oh you fancy bag
damn there's a lot I have I I have the
rest of these I've already gone through
oh for real yeah okay this is a new one
I know
but there it is guys check it out
teddyfrish.com it's all happening
all right you seemed quite eager to tell
me about this domestic terrorist well
you said what are you doing this weekend
and uh what kind of domestic terrorism
are you doing this weekend and I thought
about a brave Warrior Craig Robinson who
was doing a lot this weekend or doing a
lot over the course of the past year as
a matter of fact what is this posed oh
he's dead this guy of spoiler alert this
is Craig Robertson uh Provo Utah's very
own
uh domestic terrorist he was making a
lot of threats against Joe Biden Joe
Brandon is uh in Utah today
um leading up to his visit uh the Secret
Service uh was aware okay well these
posts are probably not the smartest
no no it's really bad hold on let me
read them go back there's more this hey
I heard Biden's coming to Utah digging
out my old ghillie suit and cleaning the
dust off my M24 sniper rifle dark
awesome dude really cool it's really
really stupid uh in my dream I see Joe
Biden's body in a dark corner of a DC
parking garage with his head severed and
lying a huge puddle of blood I love it I
love the festive kind of colors yeah
that one is like straight like either
the bisexual bicycle or or even even
worse the transgender bride oh my God no
perhaps Utah will become famous this
week as the place a sniper took dude
what so what so what happened the Secret
Service just murdered him the Secret
Service uh it was the FBI back I believe
in uh April like
you know saw all of these threats
because he's been like threatening
elective Representatives Non-Stop and
it's like really weird guys like it'll
be like Jerry Nadler you know what I
mean and half of the people he's
threatening are like already one foot in
the grave you know what I mean he's just
like yeah I can't wait to kill Jerry
Nadler and it's like bro he's like you
could sneeze on him and he would die you
know what I mean he's like [__] himself
on camera before anyway you say anything
about Dianne Feinstein yeah it wasn't
Dianne Feinstein it definitely not Mitch
McConnell come on because I wouldn't
recommend that he's he's a uh oh I would
definitely not
anyway go ahead that's the bell for me
and uh so they should just hang out they
should make a buddy comedy Mitch and
Diana mention Diane Mitch and Diane
a story about two old [__] you can oh
yeah
your laughs
[Laughter]
[__] them anyway go ahead damn that was
that was some that was some Hollywood
bowling baby yeah that's right that's
crazy
whoa so what happened to him tell me
what happened uh so he was posting a lot
of this stuff and then in April they uh
they they basically pinged his account
see service did then they passed it over
to the FBI I believe uh two months ago
and then the FBI uh of course as Joe
Biden was you know coming into town uh
he's in town today he's in Utah today
the FBI yesterday at 6 00 a.m decided to
knock on his door
we don't know exactly what happened but
he's dead now he's [__] super dead oh
so so we don't know that we don't know
the details we just know that the FBI
murked him well okay to be fair
considering the messages he was leaving
I don't think it's insane to think that
no they had that he was probably no this
is a this is absolutely like uh one of
those [__] around and find out
situations it seems especially because
not only was he like I am going to shoot
Joe Biden in the head with this specific
rifle that I own this date in this
location he also literally said FBI I
know you're watching come and try to you
know take my guns [__] like I
will shoot you as well as long as soon
as you knock on my door so it's like the
FBI was like just so you know okay
everybody so we're probably gonna have
to kill this guy yeah yeah before we go
in just yeah they probably were you know
either laughing crying emojis up on this
[__]
checking checking so I can be sure I
have a loaded gun handy in case you drop
by again
well I said July 27th two days after my
birthday
uh there's some photos of him you know
if you want to click on that Eric Toller
uh uh thread right there has the FBI
gone woke
dude that's that's my narrative or the
is Tucker talked about the FBI gone woke
by killing him yeah
I don't know he's got it talking about
Tucker Max or whatever that Twitter show
that people watch apparently who's I
don't even know who you're talking about
Tucker Carlson tucked the dick done Carl
doesn't ring a bell for me anyway
so he had a suspended Twitter account he
was talking about you know murdering AOC
if you go up if you're going to scroll
up
um click on the uh scroll up and then
click on the gun photos because the the
the uh descriptions are really important
can you read that it's too small for me
Merrick Garland eradication tool bro
coming for me with your FBI you little
demented weasel cowardly [__]
question mark
did this guy ever try anything or was he
just trying to die by the FBI I think
this is just like door dashing suicide
by cop at this point right like taking
suicide by cop to a whole new level yeah
for the people who brought you suicide
by cop here is suicide by federal law
enforcement look at the mouse and Papa's
in the house Papa's in the house that's
what the FBI said yeah
anyway uh actually Rudy giuliani's a
huge fan of our new
she's a bit of a [__] boy you know you
know he goes down you know bring those
tits over here yeah he's like those are
my tits I I claim bring those titties
over here I claim property rights on
your tits I put an enclosure around it
that's a sexual Dance all right
um so today we are talking about besides
fair use which I have a bone to pick but
we'll do that quickly I don't want to
believe around that too much surely uh
we've got uh Crowder's downfall which I
is so delicious it's beautiful to watch
I've been I've been seeing a lot of
people I've been seeing a lot of people
talk about his like uh algo and as a
content creator I mean we're both
content creators like that's the
probably most hurtful thing you can say
about another content creator is like
when you when someone has actually
fallen off and you you Court you map
their trajectory of their falling off
and you put the analytics right there
and you go this is you uh you've done
this to yourself it said I think it's
fantastic in his case and so well earned
I mean yeah it's nice to see even his
Republican conservative fans abandoning
him in the face of absolute
uh debauchery douchebaggery
uh perverted freak [__] that he does
yeah all right so you watch the xqc
thing I did I stole it I stole it from
you it no yeah listen thank you so much
okay you actually did ask permission
which I thought was funny you don't I
mean well because you can react to it
because I I want to make sure that like
uh you know it's not cooking your
re-upload or anything you know what I
mean because there was like that bot
channel did you DMC them or I was no one
took it down yeah I was like damn right
now and they both [__] Panic yeah and
privated it those got you every time you
see one of my videos like that where
where they just do the thumbnail rip and
it's just like a straight bod rip click
on oldest videos You'll see it's all
like Roblox you know V bucks fortnite uh
how to achieve so they're watching
interestingly I wasn't sure if they were
but yeah you all [__] are on
notice no more of that [__] you
understand because they upload like xqc
uploads and I'm not having any of that
yeah they do they do all of that all
right let me ask you sure let me ask you
about the take you had okay let's hear
it okay so when I was talking to xqc and
he said oh well no you you don't react
hard enough either
and you said this is why Ethan's
argument is not good because it always
devolves into you yes you don't react
hard enough because at the end of the
day there are no clear-cut guidelines No
clear-cut Boundaries on like what to do
no like standardized best practices and
the argument always will in the eyes of
the audience especially uh develop
something so I think I I circumvented
that pretty good sorry to interrupt you
I'm not I was yeah uh it will always
evolve into uh you're not reacting hard
enough obviously there are boundaries
that I think aren't established but like
most people
uh most people understand are bad
however
especially if you're doing like long
form content
especially if you're doing live streamed
content without pre-production like you
do
um because you have your own uh version
of that as well as like the members only
broadcast there will always be
loves and and moments of like dead air
or even you getting up but that's also
live reaction here I'm talking and I
made it clear I'm talking specifically
about his YouTube channel I wouldn't
make this claim okay well that that
that's something I made clear at the
beginning so I I I so okay so we're
talking about his YouTube channel now I
would never claim that about streaming
because I agree that streaming is too
much of a gray area yeah and I don't
think it's ever even been tested so
there's not really any precedent in that
regard so in the context of talking
about his YouTube channel I have to
disagree that it's not about react
harder there is clearly zones
there's like s-tier zones which would be
for example I'll just I'll say one of my
old reaction videos which is like highly
produced with sketches it's like obvious
right yeah and then there's a massive
Gray Zone massive Gray Zone which this
podcast would probably even fall in
which would be like high high up in the
gray Zone I don't think so well
regardless I'm just trying to show you
what I mean because it's pre-cut
the the videos that we watch are pre-cut
that doesn't matter I think it does
matter even because it makes well it
doesn't matter fair use doesn't it
doesn't oh yeah yeah but I'm saying like
the way I see it your highly edited
sketch videos your sketch React videos
are those are S2 yeah those are s tier
this podcast would be like a little bit
below it but it still is like we're
we're cutting this live but every single
thing that we're looking at we already
know what we're going to be looking like
I mean like it's we can have a
discussion about it sure it's all
debatable and that's the nature of fair
use it's all up to a judge and jury to
decide based on the merits of this one
particular instance and so that's what I
mean there's like a massive Gray Zone
and I would include like myself at the
top of that Gray Zone and then like May
potentially even Sniper Wolf at the
bottom of the gray Zone yeah I've seen
now dude I've seen now below the gray
Zone yeah there's like unacceptable dog
[__] straight up content theft yeah just
like where xqc is direct re-uploads of
someone else's YouTube video would be at
the bottom right like no not even like
inside the gray Zone it's in the black
Zone yeah yeah that's what I'm saying
like black Zone would be uh the the
unacceptable barrier would be like at
the top of that barrier you have like
someone who's a streamer who like
uploads a straight VOD rip and they're
not even fully there they're like barely
reacting to it they're just like kind of
letting the video play as a substitute
agree with me for their chat to be
entertained with no I don't disagree
with you on that the only the only
element of the outside of the gray Zone
uh a conversation that we could be
having is that uh they're even in that
even in that situation there is not
enough data
um you had you pulled up uh Vince's
video or Vince's statement on it but
there's still not enough data on whether
or not that is
uh valuable or not especially if like
certain
um what do you mean is it displacing in
the algorithm is it good for a mid-sized
Channel really matter
but it doesn't really matter the reason
why it the reason why this is always not
like uh you can't [__] do this you
piece of [__] stop it and then everyone
changes their uh attitude towards it
immediately the reason why this keeps
resurfacing over and over again is
because there's inconsistency not enough
data on whether or not it is appropriate
doesn't matter well it matters because
for the most part creators don't
either out of the Year either out of
fear that they don't want to get into
trouble with the large content creator
or because they genuinely see value in
it uh they don't complain about it or
they don't do anything about it well as
xqc uh clearly exemplified by now
attacking Vince on Twitter I don't know
if you saw this I did see that that was
really [__] up gummy can you pull that
up I [__] hate that that was that was
definitely [__] up because
he's not doing uh well I don't think at
this moment well
I'm gonna pull that up I figured to help
demonstrate what you were talking about
Ethan I'd do an xqc style paint uh thing
for you so here's the chart that you
were talking about here's Ethan oh the
top outside of the gray Zone this is
actually really good and then here is
also Ethan but in the gray Zone yeah
yeah and then here's just a Sniper Wolf
down here that just mean
and then this is like dog this is like
you're stealing content and it doesn't
matter if it's good for people because
he's literally literally as leafy to
he's okay this kid literally ruined
literally I mean how do you do that
literally
um literally he's re-uploading videos
yeah period like straight up with with
very little feedback no no no no
that's not even applicable like xqc oh
yeah he uploads videos
of him
adding zero run time or like two seconds
run time and all he says is that's crazy
chat okay that is that is a re-upload
you do you do realize that that
conversation still turns into like
I I agree with you but even though I
agree with you that conversation is
still like I don't like the way you're
reacting and that can be expanded no it
doesn't because there can't be expanded
to someone like yourself even you're
wrong
saying this is crazy chat is not it's
not additive it's not critical it
literally doesn't transform you're
sitting there re-uploaded a video it's
not there's you cannot debate that I'll
give you that's my problem with I felt
like you were running D for xqc a little
bit when I watched you no uh because
you're like this whole uh react harder
thing is kind of like like you can't cry
anybody's uh I'll give you another
example technically technically
um well at the end of the day all of
this is entirely dependent on the IP
holder and what they want to do with
their IP if they don't that's my point
of life doesn't matter yeah that's why
it's like uh that's why there's always
going to be back and forth but if the IP
holder is like I don't give a [__] I
love that XC [__] watched it of
course uh oh my God chat
um but there are of course going to be
examples of people that say no actually
I don't like that and I had no way of
like even communicating that to xqc
because I was terrified that his fans
would eat my ass
um which is valid I think that is what's
happening currently with Vince so
um
what I was trying to say is if we're
looking at fair use like completely
the reality is that unless you are
directly engaging in commentary on the
video that you are currently watching
the video that you're currently watching
you can't even use it as a narrative
tool in most circumstances uh I know
this from my days working at The Young
Turks and I know this from what I
technically do in violation of like the
actual fair use laws even when I'm
uploading my YouTube videos right when I
upload my regular YouTube videos of a
news
uh when I'm providing news analysis
unless I am directly engaging in media
criticism if I'm using a news clip as a
narrative piece that is still something
that I'm technically supposed to license
out no there is an exception for uh
journalism and fair use as well there's
a clause for journalists and new stuff
you still can't use someone else's
footage to like for example I don't know
exactly what you mean but I'm going to
disagree with you I okay yeah I can't
let's say instead of me introing my my
uh video like uh Rudy Giuliani wanted to
see some titties today and we're gonna
take a look at that and then go directly
into like uh I don't know the news
article that I'm reading through instead
of doing that if I played an ABC News
broadcast that's like rudu Giuliani was
found uh you know court documents
revealed that Rudy Giuliani was really
interested in seeing some tits if I put
that clip in there and I don't actually
immediately commentate on that clip or
criticize that clip that's technically a
violation of fair use
you uh especially if you don't license
it but so I get again it depends on
these people okay the whole the account
context of the clip but okay let's say
it is so what
the reason why I'm saying that
is because
there is a lot more
that could be utilized there is a lot
more IP that that could be acted on in a
legal sense hold on you're that
currently is not acted on your CH the
the focus is changing
you're saying that IP laws to uh too
onerous and I agree with that yeah I'm
not talking about the law necessarily
I'm talking about um
this notion that certain stuff that
people do is just outright unacceptable
and not up for debate which I think that
you seem to disagree with with like
react harder this whole react harder uh
meme the reason why I brought up the
other side of it and how uh IP law if
enforced to its maximum degree would be
really messed up and would legitimately
stop any kind of video from being
created unless you are going into a
process and like you know even getting
here
I'll use this because it's not gonna
because you can see it the other one is
Green Cloud amplifier when I put this up
if this is showing in the background
like this could technically be legally
enforceable Cloud amplifier could come
and say we didn't give you rights to use
this in your broadcast and like that is
anything anyone I agree that is that is
something that I'm terrified of it's a
case-by-case basis you can sue anyone
for anything you know what I mean which
is precisely why the conversation always
goes back to are you reacting hard I
don't like the way you're reacting and
then it's entirely in the hands of the
IP holder who can say I don't like the
way you reacted I'm going to dmca you
and therefore okay let me ask you this
we all agree if you upload let's just
we're going to talk about Vince's video
I re-upload it to my channel wholesale
unacceptable
let's write yeah so now I re-upload the
channel of me just sitting there in the
corner like this
okay
it's the plot the same video re-uploaded
except there's just a square of me
sitting like this
just blankly the whole time is that
acceptable
it's dependent on what Vince thinks is
acceptable or not that means it's not
because you don't need permission to
transform content
yes but so you think that it's not
straight up indefensible to sit in a box
and stare at the camera while the video
plays
I think that it is my personal opinion
on it is that it is absolutely one not
good content and two indefensible to do
that however given that it's entirely up
to the IP holder themselves to either
make a claim dmca the channel you say
you could say about anything I mean no
no but but the reason that takes the
react harder thing I want to talk about
that so the reason why I'm stating that
the reason why I'm mentioning this is
the reason why a lot of people are still
going to be confused at the end of this
conversation because no matter what
happens we are not going to
end up with clear-cut boundaries like
well-defined boundaries that are even
enforceable not legally but like
enforceable from a terms of service or
uh
there will never be terms of service
because it's not a policy thing yeah
but I I disagree because I feel like
it's pretty obvious when it's not when
it's clear-cut wrong
like if you were to sit in a box and
stare which is essentially what xqc does
he adds stuff like what what crazy what
so that is that's not different than
sitting in a box and staring I don't
disagree with you on that I do I do
think that from a like content
standpoint uh I think that it is
unacceptable to do that
so you mentioned uh sniperwolf you said
that it's in the bottom of the gray area
which means that there is like at least
some level of debatability that means
that there's some level of acceptability
she talks through it right yeah more
importantly than that I think it's like
pre-clips like it's it's pre
but like the pre-selected eclipse
the it's like a bad faith versus good
day Faith and like I think that
sniperwolf is
I'd have to look at it frankly I'd have
to look at it really close many people
would disagree with you on that like
people well I like Jack's films it's
completely unacceptable that's it's in
the gray Zone that's my point Hassan
yeah what I'm simply stating is
depending on the IP holder and depending
on how the crowd is receiving it clearly
people want to even watch xqcb in the
[__] corner and go does it matter if
they want to watch it bro it doesn't
transform it
I know but they find it transformative
enough if it's a substitute if it's a
substitute for the original video itself
when excuse face is associated with it
then there's enough people like his
argument I think is I'm gonna try to do
my best to argue from his perspective
even though I don't agree with
re-uploading his videos like in the way
that he re-uploads them for sure or
re-uploading a video that's a straight
vodrip where the only feedback you have
is come on chat that's crazy like the
clip that you put together I think
that's silly
um however
I think his argument is I don't care if
these videos are out there if they
monetize it if if someone else of a
smaller content creator has an MCN and
they can monetize it then they should
monetize my video that's great that's
number one number two if they don't want
it and they want to dmca it I'm
perfectly uh happy to DMC it as well
because I'm not using YouTube as a way
to to make additional money generate
additional Revenue I'm using it as a way
for people to watch these vods that they
normally would not be able to take he
put on Twitch don't upload it to YouTube
it doesn't matter that they have
remedies it's not their responsibility
to chase him down to [__] remedy his
theft I don't know I don't do me it's
like there I don't I don't I think that
even by having this conversation it's
running defense for xqc a little bit it
is because it it
it um you know it creates
it creates a sense of like uh like
there's some conversation to be had
about it and I just don't think there is
I really don't not in his case
yeah you know I mean you go all the way
back to uh Jax what was his name
Jinx everybody I don't know anything
about Jinx was a guy who was uploading
videos exactly like xqc does today
it was like how long ago was that like
six years ago everybody agreed that
somehow what this guy was doing was Mega
[__] up and he got like bullied off
the internet yeah now all of a sudden
xqc is doing it and all these twitch
streamers are doing it and it's like oh
we like them they're cool now we're
gonna upload it's even worse frankly
than what he used to upload and you know
now that the cool guy is doing it uh uh
let's have a conversation about if this
fair use or not I mean it's [__]
absurd in my opinion it's absurd it's
just wrong period black done okay so
it's not fair use and the reason why
it's it's not fair use I don't think
that it would uh be it it would be
deliberated on in a way that is like
good for xcc if that actually came down
to it if by some Insanity that uh xqc's
YouTube channel was DMC Aid uh for one
of those vods yeah and then he countered
it and it actually went to a court of
law he's getting [__] eviscerated
right right which is why he understands
that which is why he doesn't want to you
know he doesn't care
um however that is precisely what I'm
trying to say is that fair use is
uh is is far more expansive like you
have been able to create you've actually
done something crazy and have been able
to create some precedent
but beyond that precedent
fair use in the way that we still
analyze it in the way that we still uh
utilize it
even in ways that the content Watchers
don't understand
but take for granted
is still outside of the boundaries of
fair use it's not even a discussion
about legality okay because again who's
to decide well the reason why I'm
passionate from the legality point of
view is because
you're asking like why are people not
getting uh more mad at this or why are
people not stopping this if that's your
question then xqc should be ostracized
this should not be a norm that people
are like yeah this is cool he's just
re-uploading people's content whole
[__] sale this should not be like
something that people can do without
catching the whole you know
watching [__] from the whole internet
it's not it's not even about fair use
law yeah it's about right and wrong okay
ultimately I think if I'm going to be as
like um in order to wrap this up I think
what you're trying to say is that there
should be some well-established
boundaries that are not legally
enforceable obviously because
technically everything that you
mentioned in the gray area is quite
literally a violation potentially a fair
use right
so it's not we're not talking about like
legally enforceable no uh fair use we're
talking simply about uh what level of
commentary
uh like what is the bottom level of
commentary of acceptability and how can
we in and what's below that some kind of
yeah how can we create some kind of
social enforcement of it by ostracizing
people for violating it clearly and and
regularly right that's what you're
trying to say
uh because if that's your point of view
there's a block Zone there's a black
Zone if if that's your point of view if
that's your point of view I agree with
you especially when it is uh in an
effort in a way to protect smaller
content creators that want to generate
content creators doesn't [__] matter
you don't get to steal anybody's [__] no
I know I'm saying it's like I I agree
with you especially as in like I agree
with you across the board and especially
on uh defending smaller content creators
so I agree with you on that front if
you're talking about social
ostracization so what is your point
regarding the black Zone because that's
the part I'm I'm curious regarding the
black Zone social ostracization would
still ultimately rely on
um let's not even talk about consequence
just right or wrong
do I think it's wrong to re-upload
someone else's Vaude or your own VOD rip
that you didn't actually uh put a
tremendous amount of effort into yeah I
I said that already we agree on that
onto YouTube especially is it because
then it absolutely operations
okay so then in regard to the black Zone
the react harder meme isn't really
applicable
the criticism is still you're not
reacting hard enough
right but sometimes that's valid
criticism yeah it is like when you're
just sitting there it is of course
you're not reacting hard enough so
what's wrong with saying that in the
black Zone well it's because it's not
enforceable in any meaningful capacity
we're not talking about enforcement so
that boundary that you're setting is a
boundary that you're setting is a
boundary that your audience is setting
it's it's ultimately not
a boundary that is always going to be
the same for every single person just
like you mentioned xcc is well liked so
for a very long time it was not
something that they yelled at him for I
I'm not very well video you have a dog
in this fight so I don't know if you're
ever gonna be willing to meet me there
well I have two dogs in the fight
this is we're talking about like prac in
practice application
um in theory I also personally uh
believe that information is not a scarce
good like there is no scarcity in
information you put it out there what
does it have to do with re-uploading
someone's video
um everything it's just that is the the
basis of IP IP is technically IP on
content is technically
a concept that uh
that that is is no different than
enclosures but this time in the digital
sphere enclosures on uh art
if we're talking about in theory if I'm
talking about idealistically
um I that's my second dog in the fight I
think that uh limiting information makes
it
uh harder for new uh forms of derivative
RPA but so are you against all IP law
um
I don't know where the exact boundaries
would be as we talked about last week
yeah let's not rehash that yeah but uh
anyway
um
yeah there's actually a YouTuber who's a
Libertarian uh that
unironically has a very interesting
argument about copyright tax
like he believes that America could
Implement some sort of copyright tax
across the board and then there would be
no copyright in general
you could still
um you know you could still go after
people in in litigation for uh
re-uploading your content in its
entirety so there's still a space of
protection there but overall there would
be a massive you know multi almost
trillion dollar fund that you go that
you spend on media that the government
would spend therefore limiting at least
one element of of profit seeking from
the field of content creation and
copyright and this would actually open
up uh the other side of the conversation
that I've advocated for which is access
to copyrighted material without having
enough money that's why I talked about
like growing up in turkey and why I
believe in piracy if you don't have uh
the money or access to be able to
receive this copyrighted I just um yeah
you know I just want to make it clear
because I'm not talking about any of
that and I don't want it to be confused
I'm just talk but anyway
has some notes she says
and I think there's a good point we do
we shouldn't even call what xqc does
react it's a watch party
and when you frame it like that
it's a watch party then you really
understand
that it's actually a really good point
it is a watch party it's not you're not
wrong about that at all so there you go
you're just sharing yeah this video
you're not yeah transforming it yeah so
there it is I think xqc would agree with
that
technically it is a watch party
there's a watch party mechanism on uh on
Twitch as well as a matter of fact the
only issue is given International IP
restrictions the watch party uh
mechanism only works for Amazon Studios
properties and it basically destroys
your VOD and it shuts off people that
aren't in Canada or aren't in the United
States of America from actually watching
your stream it like Geo locks your
stream which is very shitty that's
that's the black Zone we're not watch
parties should not be re-uploaded period
that's it yeah no react harder it's just
not even okay anyway whatever so that's
that
the watch part but I do think the watch
party distinction is actually very good
yeah yeah but I do I think that's like
xqc watching a whole ass movie and then
um whatever
the point is that I do think that the
way you frame the react harder argument
isn't a total totally
fair or accurate and does end up running
defense for people like xqc who are
re-uploading watch parties to YouTube
thank you
sure I'll agree
I rest my case
all right that's just me now okay shut
up xqc oh yeah I wanted to show this
just to kind of I I think this is the
point this is the point where I have to
do the worm do the [__] work I can't
do the world I can't I can't that's why
I'm extra on he owned you well I I told
this yesterday but when I was doing my
members live
they're like dude do the worm I was like
hell no I'm not getting that in that
video out on the internet that's true
you're a man with a lot of videos of
himself out on the internet that your
haters use against you all the time
[__] personally uploaded yeah there's
already me and a diaper I don't need
[__] work it's so stupid when they're
like they do that to me too or like the
Andrew Tate Fanboys would be like
remember when Hassan was in a dress I'm
like bro I put that out there that's
like a very viral Tick Tock that you are
clipping to be like I owned you well you
think I accidentally dressed like a
beautiful woman yeah you know what I
mean like what do you think no that took
[__] an hour of makeup idiot mm-hmm
yeah I mean it's the same and I look
[__] hot so in this uh conversation
with xuc
he says that if anybody wants to come to
me and say Hey you stole my [__] I'll
take it down I'll pay them I'll do
whatever it takes please please please
I'm so sorry yeah this was [__] up so
as I told him this guy Vince vintage
actually uh shared his message now this
morning or last night this this message
pissed me the [__] off this is some
scumbag level [__]
now in basically a contrast to what he
said the day before he says this Vint
Vince vintage guy tagging him he Praises
real mizkid for doing the exact same
thing I did now let me go back and say
that Vince vintage already in his
message explained why he called out xqc
and not other react streamers so already
he's pretending to not know that uh to
make him look like dishonest or
hypocrite for doing the exact same thing
I did and flips it on me when the tide
shift shut the [__] up [__] you've
always been an [__] can I say
something about this part
oh he didn't just flip it on him when
the tide shifted I didn't even know this
uh I've responded to his tweet he
tweeted about how much he loved my
reaction to his video in [__] 2022
way before the tides that ever shifted
uh actually as a matter of fact when
people were ripping on me for reacts and
saying Mr Chariot got like an excuse he
did ironically like so no this guy has
been like uh obviously openly uh openly
praising uh uh twitch streamers that
have reacted to his videos in a way that
he considers to be good and
transformative and also beneficial to
his channel for a year like for an
entire [__] year also if somebody who
[__] you stole is like yeah I didn't
like the way you do that then you shut
the [__] up and listen yeah that's it
dude let me give you a great example of
this there's a YouTuber out there who is
made a [__] ton of videos about me okay
they were 100 right when uh they got mad
at me for for uh playing their video and
not watching it which is ironic because
I don't think any of the videos that
they've made about me
uh since then features this part I've
apologized I've apologized multiple
times and said like I'm changing certain
things you're absolutely right about
this like I apologize three [__]
years ago now that that person they
still make videos all the time but I am
truly I am I was wrong I I owned up to
it I was [__] wrong
um even though I hate when people try to
draw uh uh you know Farm drama as much
as they possibly can official like that
but
um you have to you have to admit if
you're doing this sort of thing
and someone gets mad at you and I hadn't
even re-uploaded that by the way to
YouTube my [__] chair reactor or
whatever even though that's where the
chair react meme comes from
I was wrong and I stopped doing that you
have to you can't on the one hand be
like if you dmca me I have no issue with
this uh I will pay you 10x and then turn
around and [__] [__] on the person be
like that's a paid actor because you're
then proving their points dude yeah well
yeah and during the debate he was like
yeah dude no I'll make it up to them I
care so much about them then he goes
this guy blatantly lies in a tweet
because I didn't respond to his DM 12
hours later not true it was two days
later after you literally said in the
debate I'll pay him right now
12 hours because I was flying to Vegas
[__] how long's that flight
flying yet we had sent an email two days
before I talked to Vince you know why he
didn't see this email
they sent it to some random [__]
email for his like manager
he didn't even it didn't even go to his
box and by the way remember he said 10x
here's his editor reaching out I can
compensate you for the full Revenue oh
really [__] what happened to 10x
why don't you open with that you [__]
scammer
um
so here he shows I guess him saying
mizkiff showing Love Again worse the
Tweet of him saying thanks xqc for
reacting to my video why didn't you show
that one because he [__] doesn't like
the way you react to his video
yeah
um
he's also sent him a DM and by the way I
know Felix you see those DMS because I
when I type you [__] you respond within
five seconds
well you know he's he's out there
flexing on you flexing on his haters
bro he has his whole house he has your
whole house on his wrist okay
and then he goes I thought I'd stay
silent and let the storm pass but know
everyone jumped on that back when it's
currently spreading lies I'm coming for
you awesome dude really cool [__] job
here making good on on the way you steal
content scum scumbag dude
petulant [__] child
incapable of taking I think any
criticism I think uh the way xuc
presented himself if he uh if he
actually was like oh yeah I'll make
amends and uh you know responded to
Vince's DM and was like here give me
your PayPal uh and then
and then replied with uh a a way to make
amends I think that this would this
conversation would be a little bit
different considering that that would
mean that he is actually fulfilling what
he told you on the stream I mean listen
I think is what you're I mean I think
that's the right thing to do yeah I'd be
if I was xqc after that conversation I'd
be pretty motivated to pay that guy
immediately
and not wait two days and then lie
instead has only been 12 hours such a
scumbag dude
I hate that guy do you want to know why
I I have a text to Vegas just three
hours you want to know why I have a dog
in this fight quote unquote it's not to
like defend xcc or whatever it's because
I do worry that if more rigorous dmca
Protocols are implemented on Twitch in a
similar automated fashion to YouTube the
live streaming on that website would be
rendered useless because that's one part
of the reason why YouTube live streaming
is so difficult to accomplish and you
know this better than anybody else
um lots of people do it I do it yeah I
know but it's not the same as live
streaming on
Twitches which is dominant in the live
streaming uh sphere if it happens it
will be because of people like xqc who
just sit there and watch full episodes
of Hunter Hunter
The Dark Knight begins if it happens is
a result of that of the what is actually
happening there but that's another
that's that's like a I we shouldn't even
get I was gonna say like
um I think uh old IP
from Mega corporations should
immediately have a shelf life like I
agree you know I don't think I don't if
you're not if you're not circulating
DVDs a master chef and New Seasons of
MasterChef are coming out you should
release the IP which some companies kind
of do actually you know uh
the window for um
for uh what's it called when it goes
public domain it used to be 14 years I
do which was great I wonder what
happened
and now it's like the uh the lifetime of
an author plus 50 Years or or Disney has
like used different things as well to be
like well technically also the the next
of kin also counts or some [__] like
that too yeah 14 years would be great
that's enough time to make some money
and then thank you that is I totally
agree with that but at the same time I
[__] hate that it's like like and I
mean it by the way for those of you who
are wondering what do you mean like The
Dark Knight yes [__] The Dark
Knight Rises okay after 14 years after
14 [__] years that's how you should
be able to watch a goddamn movie on your
[__] stream and and repackage it if
you want to and re-upload it if you want
to it's [__] ridiculous that you
can't do that it used to be that way 14
years of ample time to make money yes
from your investment and then in the
public good yeah absolutely absolutely
ridiculous and also a lot of people
don't see that if that was the case by
the way you and I completely agree on
this it seems a lot of people don't see
that like if you are able to do that
you now have so many unique ways of
being able to make new content because
all art at the end of the day whether
it's uh it's the silliest artistic
interpretation it's the silliest medium
it's a [__] Tick Tock whatever all
art at the end of the day is derivative
it it it is taking from something else
and either pointing to it
or directly carbon copying it this
happens in music all the time it's
probably like the foundation of the
K-pop uh music industry which is
massively successful we love BTS you
know what I mean
butter yeah butter yeah Butter's my
favorite Dynamite I'm a dynamite boy
Dynamite yeah I love that oh yeah so I
guess what I'm trying to say is uh you
know stop Gangnam Style stop limiting
art from uh that is not BTS from being
made yeah what the [__] what the [__]
did you just say we love no I do love
Psy I actually do love separately that's
not that's not BTS that he that's Ethan
is saying that I'm not saying but this
is for all BTS yeah this is BTS I love
Psy as well separately from BTS because
he's a Anti-Imperialist Legend yeah
Gangnam Style
my Theodore loves that song incidentally
hell yeah Gangnam Style that's a great
song He's catchy so anyway all right
let's move on thank you uh for the uh
conversation
um Hassan yeah leftovers over uh we're
done
um well we're never gonna talk to one
another ever again let's continue to
straight to the Crowder stuff because we
actually spent an hour discussing that I
know and I don't want to miss out on
Crowder's downfall which is such a
pleasure to witness I enjoy it so much
and uh it couldn't happen to a worse guy
and Shout Out Sam Cedar uh let's see so
a couple weeks ago there was a mediaite
uh mediaite report where they talked
about several ex-staffers who said they
were sexually harassed by Crowder
constantly whipping his dick out or even
texting dick pictures to them
that's how that's how Ethan and I
communicated with one another for the
leftovers yeah yeah that's the pre-show
planning right there yeah
so now there's a new uh scoop coming out
by the same company saying that for
Stephen Crowder staffers exited the show
after intense interrogations and insane
ndas in the wake of calculate
so here check this out Steven Crowder
made all of his employees
sign a Draconian hundred thousand dollar
breach of contract penalty uh
if they if they talk to anyone about the
show which I'm I'm sure that's illegal
are men not allowed to be men anymore is
what I ask no I mean
back in the day men were allowed to whip
their [__] out at their staffers and
yeah you know do whatever they want
friends your family we ever used to have
rate buttons bro it was all good yeah it
was it was uh Matt Lauer
Matt Lauer's button now now we have to
do other kinds of buttons to stop the
broadcast because goddamn woke liberal
left coming after us dude
yeah holy [__] back in the day you could
you know kidnap and and engage in
imprisonment of a co-worker that you
fancy now you can't even say it now I
can't even fantasize openly and and
verbally about it yeah how did you
become gay so the the beautiful irony is
this is of course he's sitting down all
of his employees and he's like I will
[__] kill you if you talk about this
show again and then immediately five
people went to uh mediaite and reported
on their conversation is that awesome
five current and former staff members
the people who are still in his midst he
still has moles
uh the agreement which was reviewed by
mediaite where emails to current louder
with Crowder employees on July 26th and
read in part employee maintains its
promise and Covenant
okay bro it's not [__] we're not
talking about Jesus Christ here there's
no Covenant that's what you think
hey I'm just trying to I'm just trying
to make money covenant not disclose
confidential information as defined in
the amendment company will provide
employee with confidential information
during the period in which employee is
employed by company can I just say
something or they'll be liable for a
hundred thousand dollars go ahead so
they uh
a lot of companies have these kinds of
ndas and non-compete clauses that they
have some of which is legally
enforceable others are not depending on
your state especially if you're in
California uh good luck getting any kind
of uh NDA to be enforced
um however
one thing that I I guess uh find really
funny is like uh for example if you work
for like a big uh weapons manufacturer
let's say you work at like uh Lockheed
Martin right
um there's a lot of proprietary
technology that they do not want uh uh
in the hands of their competitors
Northrop Grumman Boeing yada yada so I
like to think that Stephen Crowder's
penis is the proprietary technology that
they do not want out there they're like
dude this is really important for the
content creation process please do not
show anyone else or tell anyone else
that I'm whipping my dick out I want a
helicopter putting it on your [__]
shoulder uh in in meetings
uh this is very important it's very
important when you like take your dick
or your ball skin and tuck it over your
dick I was just thinking remember that
one guy yeah that one guy caught us from
my friends my hamburgering is a Nash is
a matter of National Security do you
think the 14-year statute should apply
to Steven's [__]
yeah Stephen Stephen should also be uh
no longer be paywalled we should all see
it he wants to show it to the world
hamburger with your dick in your balls
all right that's where I heard it uh so
let's see here uh he made them agree to
this I hereby acknowledge that said
damages are reasonable dumbass and do
not constitute a penalty and I further
agree that I will not contest the
reasonableness of said liquided liquid
liquidated damages and any such action
commenced by either party with respect
to this amendment so there's zero
[__] shot that's legal and I
guarantee
I don't know like bro Texas is [__]
wild like Texas is like dude how are you
going to make somebody and I I'm sure he
pays his employees dog [__] just because
he's a scumbag but there's no the
chances are most of them are not even
making a hundred thousand dollars a year
no absolutely you're going to debt to
Crowder yeah
um
it's uh there's two sides of the story
that I that I find particularly funny
one is that like these guys are like I
got skin in the game dog like I really
just want to do like super reactionary
white supremacist anti-worker videos
without having your [__] on my shoulder
you know what I mean like I'm In It For
the Love of the Game right I love I love
presenting the ideas uh out to the world
I want to be a part of the content
creation process like I'm a doe-eyed uh
right-wing Zealot
and and now all of a sudden you're
interfering with that process and that's
kind of [__] up it's not cool in in in
many ways it's so funny it's like uh do
you remember that article that came out
I think it was on the Atlantic like a
couple years back where it was like all
right women are very upset that the
alt-right men are mistreating them well
it's like it's like the English or
Americans that go to Isis and then they
come back they're like the men are
actually super mean there yeah like what
what are you expecting what the [__] are
you why the oh okay why the alt-right's
most famous women disappear no no this
is a newer article this is uh I I think
there was another one buried apparently
under the floorboards of Nathaniel
klansman yeah there's another one that
was like Faith Goldie and Lauren
Southern and like all these alt-right
women were like very upset that the
white Supreme yeah they're alright women
are terribly upset that all right men
are treating them terribly what are you
talking about girl I see you on Twitter
all the time backing them up these are
the alpha males that you dream of it's
like what was your expectation listen
let it I lock your takes on Twitter but
it ain't right for a woman to be talking
out like that now someone's coming out
and being like wow everyone around me is
so racist I hate that they do not value
my opinion at all yeah yeah people here
at the daily wire
don't seem to like black people that
much well she doesn't like black people
that much either so
so let's see um
yeah they had to sign the NDA by Friday
stuff to happen to black people oh okay
whoa
hold on your response uh no that's it's
white people that's what I don't want uh
or specifically Dan Crenshaw oh no no I
would never I'm wearing I'm wearing his
let's not go there state flag right now
on my chest what do you mean what you
can substitute for chile Puerto Rico you
know what I mean you can
I love this this is so versatile like
yeah whoever you know wants to get a
piece can get a piece it does look
Yeehaw though yeah Lone Star baby
so he said y'all gotta sign this NDA by
Friday and response his staff is just
leaving in Exodus
which is fantastic we're having a louder
with Crowder diaspora actually at this
moment they're in Exile Stephen was
livid a source close to rumble told
mediaite he and Gerald Morgan uh the his
producer that little Peter Pan
just to describe his physical appearance
down not to denigrate his lack of hair
okay I'm glad you I'm glad you specified
that yeah yeah I'm a bald activist
don't don't don't virtue signal Hassan
come on so he said um he he and Gerard
Morgan Gerald Morgan said they knew
someone was talking to the author of
this hit piece based on the article they
said whoever text messages form
employees about us not being able to
hang out with them would be given
amnesty if we confessed by 2PM [__]
thinks he's in like a spy movie
all right if any of you just fess up to
talking to the media I'll give you
amnesty bro we won't behead you
yeah there's zero percent chance he's
not [__] them over big time okay if
I'm if I'm working at the louder or
Crowder racism Factory I'm like nope not
telling anybody about that [__] okay I'm
keeping that to my damn self yeah uh he
said uh
let's see if no one confessed then they
would see it as malice no one confessed
nobody did confess so they started
interrogating people sounds like a
really good work uh healthy work
environment over there yeah
well you know
was it you who talked to the media damn
it man
I mean how do you how do you even
torture Stephen Crowder employees like
because they're playing it they're
playing a role in the content creation
of some of the worst content anyone's
ever seen like what are they making you
watch Stephen Crowder videos because
that would be [__] unbearable well he
breaks up at a small room terrigation
room
and he's just pantless and they just
stare at his [__] until they're either
so mad it doesn't work
sure
yeah he's a man so he says if you're not
okay with oh this is my favorite
if you're not okay he told his employees
with guys playing with sack tap
then this isn't the place for you what
because if you're not okay with guys
playing sound you put it in writing I
was gonna say that is definitely grounds
for like legal action if you put that in
writing I think it's I mean it sounds
like he said it in front of a group of
people though something tells me he does
not have HR that's probably a good guess
yeah well yeah my first time oh so oh so
you're gonna you're gonna wrongfully
terminate everybody and you just said
that
for not being okay with sexual
harassment
that's such a crazy thing listen your
honor
kind of a buzz kill when I take my dick
out that's why they're fired
after interrogation of current staffers
four employees Departed the company the
NDA was insane said the source close to
Crowder most employees were scared
because of it some talk to lawyers about
it because they were afraid but thought
if they didn't sign it that would
incriminate themselves
it was like the Red Scare up in Up In
Crowd louder with Crowder
he was intimidating Stevens increasing
calls his penis the Red Scare right it's
like a dog's dick that's what I've heard
allegedly from way more like Plum color
you know it's like a lipstick Plum color
like it's just beaten and yeah it's kind
of like it's like it's like hell like a
dog's dick
he just always wears a super tight [__]
ring and it's just like it's cutting off
like a little yam yeah
oh God uh he was intimidating they said
Steven's increasing justification of his
workplace sexual behavior between men
makes a lot more male employees
uncomfortable he says it's joking but it
doesn't seem like a joke to anyone
anymore I love his insistence that he is
not he will not stop sexually harassing
people damn it this is part of the
fabric of the culture no it doesn't work
for me either
this is very important part of my
content creation process
either
uh here's my favorite part is that in
the wake of all of this if you basically
can trace it from when he got that 50
million dollars cash on the table offer
from daily wire which he shoved in their
face
he has been on a collision course his
numbers have tanked bro
look at this guy God uh divorced
publicly got absolutely owned by daily
wire there was a point there where I
thought like Tim Poole would have like
sided with him because it felt like the
audience he did kind of didn't he he did
because the audience like yeah we do
love racism actually thank you did
Jordan Peterson do yeah for five minutes
before he knew before he knew it was
like [__] on his employer
yeah no wait side note did you get any
updates about your debate with JP oh
yeah uh I was supposed to debate Jordan
Peterson at Oxford Union Hall in uh I
think like October or November some
point uh I was very excited and then I
talked about how I was going to do the
worm to him and then immediately that
night I found out that he backed out no
okay it's not related to the worm thing
that's a joke but he did uh he did bail
um
[__] he went through that it's a
[__] coward I don't know why he
bailed I'm I'm willing to give him the
benefit of doubt they my management said
that he pulled out because of some
scheduling conflict or whatever
[__] you can move things around pull
out I want to believe it I was I was
willing to go to [__] England to to
debate this guy in person you know I
don't even liking uh uh Kai is so cute I
love how she's laid out like yeah she's
pancaking right now Kaya is for those of
you at home who can't see he's so long
she looks like a rug yeah
look at stuffed bro yeah she looks like
a bear rug oh god um so here's Crowder's
Rumble views uh starting during his uh
massive launch here and
which by the way already in place
because it's Rumble right like
we know that uh websites outside of I
mean even YouTube has like botting
problems right like every website has it
but obviously like the more legitimate
ones that especially deploy a lot of
AdSense and AD revenue is their primary
source of Revenue generation and profits
do a fairly decent job of of stopping
any kind of manipulation from happening
and they don't need it and frankly I
think botting is fairly expensive like
it's not doesn't make that much sense to
do it the only reason to do it on
YouTube would be ego
well
we'll put on Rumble for the same reason
right but the company has a vested
interest that's the difference exactly
so
um you know there's there's a lot of
that happening in Rumble for sure one
one really good way to identify that is
if you look at that same exact website
uh or the daily active users when
Stephen Crowder is not there are they
consistent are they uh you know are they
high
uh and and I I don't believe their Vaude
views are are legitimate either but uh
there it was he barely broke a hundred
thousand views check this out man his
most recent video on the platform barely
broke a hundred thousand views and his
preceding video only has 59 000. I
should say that that is now outdated
because this was uh published earlier
this week or last week because just the
other day he had his big comeback which
we're going to be talking about in a
second which has gotten I checked this
morning I think it's at a million views
a big drop but you know what it's a big
announcement so come back actually means
something different to Crowder that's
when he comes on his employees back yeah
literally not even a joke don't don't
laugh at that that's illegal to laugh at
if you go to his YouTube channel and I
know he's he's basically migrated to
rumble butt he's still been posting here
consistently and they used to get decent
views but here's a full episode an hour
and 110 000 this one has 61 000
uh well this one has six hundred
thousand so congratulations I guess on
that this one has 49 000 I mean it is a
graveyard oh no the The Bell the Bell is
ringing for Steven Crowder's YouTube
brother
this is your father
join me
join me Crowder
oh no
together we can expose our dicks the the
desiigns of hell
yeah looking at his YouTube vids man his
mug Club announcement 63 000 views So It
Begins louder with Crowder 124 000 views
hottest day ever 110k uh views it's
crazy that a channel that was like
consistently uploading videos went to
uploading videos like twice a month from
daily to twice a month
and their viewership did not adjust
because the reality is if you're
uploading daily your view counts are
supposed to be lower
um if you right right like uh the
difference between a channel like mine
for example where I upload daily I'm
always gonna have uh you know if I'm if
I get like 200 to 300 000 views of video
but I'm uploading daily that's good if I
were to make like longer uh more
comprehensive analysis videos on my
YouTube page and I upload it twice a
month
that would probably mean that I would
get views that accumulate
uh and probably be like 1 million plus
per video correct he's had the exact
opposite right where he's like
uploading twice or three times or four
times a month instead of like every day
and his view count is plummeted as well
really bad and so well he just had his
big comeback and this is a Twist that I
frankly did not see
[__] Alex Jones is becoming a
full-time cast member on louder with
Crowder okay first question is how
desperate is Alex Jones his life is
really [__] if he's joining this
sinking ship well I mean he did get hit
with the largest defamation suit
in the history of the United States of
America oh you're right it did cross it
did beat uh the Dominion Fox News one
yeah
I do how did they calculate the damage
yeah it was over a billion oh the okay I
remember the punitive damages yeah
the actual damages were low it was the
punitive damages yeah he's just a giant
piece of [__] that was like a billion
that's awesome
but um
isn't he still doing uh
his show
yeah is he still doing it it's unclear
uh maybe he will uh give some clarity on
uh this but um this video that we're
gonna see uh their their news conference
uh that they published announcing this
um I should say I I don't think that he
will actually be full-time on louder
with Crowder it's more their uh they're
they're starting a network the mug Club
is a network now so it's always good he
I think he will have his own show under
the louder with Crowder banner and I'm
sure he'll pop up on the other shows I'm
very excited to see like Alex Jones and
the Hodge twins and and some other like
failed comics in the 90s on the mug club
network oh my lord your life what's
another dumbass crystalia's friend Jim
Brewer
yeah he's in this video he's there for
the [__] for the press conference yeah
you better watch out what you say
brother you're about to be clipped oh
yeah shipped into the next [__] video
dude you better watch out are you
kidding I've been [__] on Brian
Callan since day one I'm just saying
they're gonna put him in the promo again
they put Dan in the problem oh yeah
clip of Brian on Joe Rogan he's like if
anybody bullies me I'm showing up at
their house here Brian Callan you're a
[__] and a [__] loser uh-oh and
you're
how do I word this
let me get the button ready what was
written about Chris DeLeo what was
alleged about him there was a mysterious
friend
I think uh I see what you're getting at
and I believe Brian Callan has
allegations of his own right oh Jesus
yeah you have allegations on allegations
allegedly your allegations have
allegations the right way the right wing
is crazy bro they slap you with the they
slap you the allegation and uh
immediately the everyone on the right
way media is like oh dude come oh great
okay that's I'm sorry to say this but
that's literally what happened to
Fouseytube
two days ago like faucy tube he was
getting Mega canceled for this really
crazy clip of him you you yeah he was
anyway
I saw bits and pieces on Twitter and I
was like I don't know this person I
don't want to know another character I
don't want to like put it in my brain
and like lose formative memories that's
fair first kiss listen uh that's fair
yeah let's hold on to those I have too
much I have you know the hard drive is
full man I don't want to reset [__] I
got you I can't even remember my address
my work address yeah
um it's cool you just show it on your
anyway he picked up a drunk girl a drunk
sex trafficked girl on his live stream
and then so he was getting Mega canceled
by everybody and then Tristan Tate
reaches out and he's like yo shout out
to my new best friend Tristan date
and uh Ida Ross reaches out and train
wreck reaches out and now he's like
getting a a deal with a kick
so it pays to it's a very odd thing to
do as a media company to be like oh this
person
um everyone's yelling at them
because they uh what was it he he like
hooked up with someone who was drunk
that was uh it was it was crazy it was
like sex trafficking in the past she
told him like she was telling him about
how she was sex trafficked and she was
forced into prostitution and she was
really drunk so he bought her a drink
and then it's not funny and then and
then 10 minutes later takes her to the
bathroom and and allegedly does stuff
with her there it's pretty wild like to
put it mildly regardless of what
actually happened and I don't know
anything about the situation like oh
yeah he also looking at the looking at
the situation and being like well that's
the guy we right as this is happening
this is the guy we gotta immediately
have in our ranks is a wild thing to do
I don't I don't really understand at
least like
get some clarity before you [__] jump
on the you know before you dive into
these guys all have allegations they're
like hey dude no allegations are crazy
aren't they bro dude these women be
lying stab me up brother
where'd that women be lying Club well
and Stephen Crowders in Stephen
Crowder's case is not the women that be
lying it's the men that be lying he's
got a problem as well he constantly he
loves showing his dick to dudes he also
loves kissing dudes not sure if he's
shown his dick to women that would be
gross I think he even said I don't show
it to the ladies because that's not
funny yeah that's not but like to the
guys I love I love just who amongst us
doesn't want to just like uh you know
put their [__] on a fellow uh uh fellow
co-worker's shoulder you know yeah it's
just a way of showing affection and love
for your dear how you make content man
that's how you get the good stuff this
is the big announcement Alex Jones is
joining the Mud Club
what's interesting to me is that Stephen
Crowder is very delicate and it seems
that he has a track record of butting
heads with anybody who
takes the Limelight from him even a tiny
bit so I wonder how Crowder is going to
cope with Alex Jones who is a star
who is more talented funnier and crazier
more creative than Crowder Kyle Jones
yeah
he's going to turn into the beat he's
the beta
yeah Alex is going to Alpha the [__] out
of it I guess does Alex have it in him
to to be the to submit to Stephen Crouse
no no [__] no what if he really needs
the money though well but I don't even
think it's a Stephen Crowder will just
because Alex Jones is who he is he's an
incredible performer you know what I
mean has tons of fans he is gonna get
butt hurt he is going to feel insecure
yeah and he's going to start to feel
some type of way even if Alex Jones
isn't doing anything to rub him wrong
so I do Wonder uh this is no there is
definitely going to be internal drama
there you're absolutely right I didn't
even consider that Alex Jones is 100
in infinitely more entertaining person
oh yeah than Stephen Crowder
yeah yeah
so funny
so here it is uh guys let's take a look
here mug Club they will destroy us well
guess what we didn't start this fight we
don't want it but if you want to fight
you better believe yeah thank God you
cannot top that dude yeah no that's
that's better than anything Steven
Crowder's ever done absolutely
this is before like people kind of get
mad at me when I say this but we don't
deserve Alex Jones like he is
that body he is yeah he's hot he's so
[__] hot he is
creating content at a higher level the
only problem is that like
other people can't appreciate him in the
way that we do where they take him
seriously and start acting out on yes uh
the the insane things that he says like
if everybody understood it as satire as
performance art like he would be a
cherished celebrity I think if Tim and
Eric produced his show yeah then he
would be yeah like right next to Eric
Andre I mean this isn't even that unique
of a perspective that's the reason why
he was in a scanner darkly and numerous
other what was it was the best parts of
the movie Paul Thomas Anderson
uh yeah I don't know
I I mean there like even when he was
doing public radio like uh he was a
fascinating figure in Austin that a lot
of people uh that a lot of people paid
attention to and thought was like
uniquely entertaining there is that
there is like when you don't think about
the genuine impact his words have on a
broader population of colloidal silver
consumers
um you know without that he's actually a
brilliant Entertainer well let's see
loving Liberal oh that's nice well yeah
he's of comedy specials uh we have he's
already insecure look at him new shows
the investigative unit which we've
discussed and again you get a free shirt
at a lot of credit.com but we have
another announcement to make uh
regarding a new shout out to the uh 50
people still watching
and the five people left working here
acquisition uh here and by the way I'll
be taking your chats here after this
we'll be taking some questions from the
Press so you can send your chats in
right now on mug club and uh we'll be
releasing more information regarding
some of the developments but this is one
that we're all
pretty excited about and again if it was
just business it wouldn't make sense
what does he mean by that if it was just
business it wouldn't make sense
he's saying he's bad of business it's
more than that like he wants to show his
[__] to Alex Jones is he saying he's
paying him too much money that it does
he's gonna lose money from this I think
he is uh this is the the
thing that he tried to do originally
with daily wire it's a continuation of
that same narrative that he's like no no
you guys don't understand like I'm
actually racist like uh I'm I'm putting
my money where my mouth is like I'm
putting
uh I'm putting 50 million dollars aside
so I can be as racist as I want to be
does that make sense that's why he's
saying it doesn't make business sense
but he's talking about hiring Alex Jones
yeah like it doesn't make business sense
like it doesn't make good business
because he's he because he's
he's a liability guy yeah yeah yeah got
it after this we'll be taking some uh
questions from the Press so you can send
your chats in right now uh on Mud Club
and uh we'll be releasing more
information regarding some of the
developments but this is one that we're
all
pretty excited about and again God he's
dead inside I mean you could just dude
he just needs I mean I shouldn't be
saying it was actually he needs a little
bit of buckle fat removal and this man
would love much much different like I
don't know why come on look at those
biceps no he's like actually jacked he's
genuinely is jacked probably on trt I
suspect
um but no matter how jacked he gets he
always has a like comical he has a
cartoonish he's like a very jovial face
Buckle fat all right Stephen get on it
yeah it wouldn't make sense
pause for laughter
this is a man who was removed from the
platforms of Apple Spotify Google
Facebook meta X whatever the hell it is
uh all on the same day but there's no
coordination
it's just coincidence
and there were by the way many people
back then who said well that's just him
he's too extreme that's just an isolated
case it won't happen to me well
all right paying attention now
wait what no because you're on Rumble
everyone so we can't pay attention wait
he goes he goes yo if Alex Jones can get
canceled for like denying the Holocaust
I don't know if he did that I don't
think he did actually he he always is
like then it can happen he does the
precursor to like uh
he does the precursor to like the lizard
people uh he doesn't tie it back to Jews
usually he'll just do the other stuff
like uh the Ross Childs and and whatever
um but remember when he talked to Kanye
and he was like no no you don't
understand no it's not the Jews and Kai
was like no no actually it is so he is a
Jewish Ally I think yeah yeah he's a big
Ally
but I like that he's like if you listen
now Alex Jones can lose a defamation
case for accusing this the parents of
slain children of being crisis actors
then it can happen to you too
people who we all expect to stand in a
line of fire who are supposed to be
brothers in arms
Tuck's tail and ran
they struck plea Bargains with the
platforms who for a period of time would
punish anyone who even hosted him as a
guest
this is the canary in the coal mine
these people at these big Tech platforms
they tell you that they'll never come
for you that you can keep your tens of
millions in revenue or millions that you
make from their platforms and really all
that means is that if you're lucky
really lucky they'll kill you last
well they tried to kill this next man
first
and if he's honest he'll tell you get on
with it bro we're here for Alex Jones
they did a lot of damage
but if there's one thing you can say
about this man love him or hate him is
that he will fight for this country with
every last breath in his body and he
just won't die uh yeah
that I can convey he'll fight to sell
you uh you know his supplements until
with the very last breath that he has in
his body that's for sure this here is a
apocalyptic slot bucket lasts for 20
years in total darkness yeah it's made
of asbestos rat poison and a mix of
Wheat and rice the thing I will never
understand about a lot of these flavors
with lead is that they are like not
Stephen Crowder I get with Stephen
Crowder he has to ham up the racism
because like he he doesn't have anything
else carrying his content but like Alex
Jones could have genuinely maybe dove
into like more acceptable conspiracies
that uh without like uh you know urging
his audience to act out violent things
on behalf of him you know what I mean he
could have done that but no he has to be
like
Omega right wing like far right I just
don't I don't understand it like he's
entertaining enough
he didn't need to do all that maybe he
is crazy I don't know
we shouldn't we shouldn't doubt him yeah
you know as much surprised by the way as
you in landing this white whale the
number one draft pick without a doubt
out there and he as well I like that he
just [__] on him and said like he has no
prospects and then was like but he's the
number one wife whale baby
call me Captain Ahab because I'm about
to [__] this whale
or well he definitely going to show him
his dick we know that
time he will launch
exclusively yeah I don't think yeah yeah
I don't think he [__] away I'm
Reinventing I'm rewriting his uh I don't
know under the muck I don't know if
Stephen Crowder recognizes that like the
blaze which he was under or the daily
wire which he almost went under the
banner of or numerous other right-wing
media platforms that he has existed
under
are almost always backed by either
Shadow donors or openly uh like big
donors that are in the oil industry for
example uh prageru daily wire they got
oil Baron Oil Barons that are back in
them right like you can't
launch
an independent media Network
specifically with
crowd-sourced Astra uh with with the
with crowdsource donations
you can't do that
you have to either engage in astral
turfing or you have to have big ticket
backers that are just gonna pump you
with a million dollars here and there
when you need it the most
I'm so jealous it is it's just not fair
where's George Soros man there's no
[__] reason that we shouldn't be like
as rich or richer than these clowns yeah
it's it's odd it's like uh it's so weird
that not that we're not doing poorly
it's so weird that billionaires won't
back me whenever I keep saying that they
should not exist it's so odd that
individually Rich building I'm pro-built
no give me that money see no and I'm not
you I'm pro-billy I like billionaire I
know but guys you listening I'm on the
show his opinions are his own yeah
George Soros are you watching
[__] demon a club umbrella starting
with his new Friday show I'm gonna be
like listen guys
everybody the buses are coming to your
neighborhood near you
we're putting everybody on these buses
and taking them to the polls in white
neighborhoods
uh here's where you can find them
I don't know
if you're auditioning maybe not you've
needed a lot more yeah and not selling
it yeah I'll work on we can put together
a pitch deck for Sora the thing is the
other another part of this is that like
um
I don't think
I think liberals care more about like
civility
and don't value just straight up
misinforming the audience and and uh
creating propaganda Beyond uh liberal
media liberal media already does that
enough so they don't see additional
value in like pumping a shitload of
money into the likes of uh I don't know
YouTubers and whatnot in the same way
that like right wing uh right-wing
wealthy people do see value in uh
misinformation and propaganda that you
can definitely get away with much
further on the YouTube side
yeah I'm thinking about actually yeah no
the laws are super crazy like unfair
against oil people man
you know like oil people they just need
they should drill wherever they want I
mean it's the lifeblood of America
well they do say that fracking isn't
like I mean I don't see what's the big
deal with fracking either
I think people people definitely don't
understand uh how how
through Decades of misinformation
through the American Enterprise
Institute creating talking points and
delivering it all the way down from Fox
News to uh these individual YouTubers uh
people people don't understand that like
that is the reason why you know 70 of
the Republican Party consider climate
change to be a hoax and more than 33
percent of Americans now across the
board consider climate change to be
false like that was deliberately crafted
propaganda it corresponds to our obvious
material realities and and uh you know
the oil and gas industry and how much of
a Stranglehold it has on our energy
development energy production
um like this was carefully done and it's
still continuing and that's why if
you're confused you're like why the [__]
doesn't anybody care look at Hawaii like
on fire right now uh you know
devastating uh devastating events
natural disasters that are supposed to
be extreme and and uh that are supposed
to happen once every 50 years 100 years
are now happening with the frequency of
like uh you know once a year at the very
least why is that changing and people
are not recognizing that well that's
because these guys care about propaganda
more than you do
that's it the only the only thing that
you hear on the climate change side that
is like a pro renewable energy more
often than not is just like a bunch of
teenage anarchists in the UK gluing
themselves to the Mona Lisa or whatever
there is no network of of uh green
energy renewable energy uh companies
that are dumping billions of dollars
into YouTubers all the way down to
YouTube God I love that I'll be the best
[__] man you know uh would you do this
uh probably I mean I had the opportunity
to do this you did yeah Alex Jones
producers reached out to me a long time
he was going to come to your to your
stream
um we were just gonna do I don't know
what we were gonna end up doing but I I
said I I chose against it because it was
this was In the Heat of like the uh the
the contest lawsuit stuff that was going
on I didn't want to like
you could have cooked them on it though
I know but I didn't want to also like
even platform him a little bit because
Alex Jones does in my opinion
uh I I have a perspective on this that
you know
uh if if someone is like completely
de-platformed and they are spreading
dangerous conspiracy theories and like
ridiculous ideas white supremacist
messaging whatnot
I don't like to have them on my stream
to even discuss their ideas because like
they've already been dealt with you know
what I mean why would I platform them
well it's a war of ideas and I I do
think you know there's two ideas about
like don't even platform them I'm of the
mind that you can have a chat with
anybody as long as you have
you know prepared to counter their
arguments I agree with a voice to
I agree with that as long as uh there is
I agree with that as long as there is uh
uh like I just weigh the pros and cons
in that situation and if the cons
outweigh the pros
um like for example if it's already been
dealt with in the sense that like this
person has like lost ridiculous ideas
but they've already they don't have like
a major audience yeah I see it as like a
win for him a win for them even if they
are humiliated in that conversation yeah
I got you it's fair all right August
18th ladies and gentlemen
that was weird
like I'm putting chemicals in the water
it's still playing wait what the [__]
happened this is this is part of it this
is their intro
did they play the bell end
for the record this is supposed to be
like the wrestler The Undertaker
okay yeah so that's not you playing the
Bell no no no okay they got they got
their own
no shot
I'm going back you can our bells are
different wait I'll play mine I'll play
that's a different belt and then and
then this is ours
oh
my God they actually paid the Death Note
yeah
I think that's homage to a wrestler
named the undertale yeah and they're
doing the Undertaker wrestling entrance
Jesus man the Undertaker is coming to
Barry Crowder's career at this point
yeah I mean I get it he's undefeated
he's a gentlemen I cannot believe they
played the death Knoll yeah
there it is Steven I don't like them
putting chemicals in the water they turn
the freaking frogs gay remember either
like remember when he said this
the greatest hits
Hitler took the guns Stalin took the
guns the guns and El Castro took the gun
yes took the guns yes more guns
1776 will commence again we have like
half a billion guns in the country
they're taking our guns
piles of guns sticking with Facebook it
is one of several companies today that
are limiting the content of far-right
podcasts Infowars Facebook apple and
YouTube have all taken down content from
Jones and his Infowars Channel when
everyone talk about Alex Jones my wife
will not let me into the house until
I've been deloused anyone who believes
in Alex Jones
devil
uh chank
you're the best for that someone
believes these theories you really gotta
go get help Alex Jones has been ordered
to pay 965 million dollars
[Music]
now there's a move to control
information that's always been and it
ought to scare people that you gotta
move to doctrinate the Children of
America if they can get you to be part
of them oh seriously come on
yeah what you don't have something newer
than that
like here's a teacher
look how there's a move to control
and it ought to scare people that you
gotta move here's the teacher with a
pride flag Emoji actually it's not even
in the classroom it's just
it's just an emoji
because they can get you to be part of a
group also the class is empty there's no
there's no kids but an environmentalist
or part of your minority group black
Latino and Indigenous people are
suffering and dying
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait what get a load of this dummy
one more time play it back look how dumb
she is on already grew black Latino and
l
they're like yeah man
these people are talking about
minorities
better restrict our homeland is white
supremacy they'll have their little
tailor-made people that they 've been
paid for to claim to be your leader
we're looking at a giant war in February
right now currently that's the
projection
why are they playing clips of him making
inaccurate predictions no he's right
he's no he's no strings Mr Thomas we are
actually at War and have been for two
years now people don't realize that I
think I think uh a bit with him with a
crystal ball would be pretty dope
entire agenda afoot to force the
population to undergo different type of
Medical Treatments namely vaccines in
2002 there is a tyrannical organization
calling itself the New World Order
pushing for
worldwide government a cashless Society
if any terrorism comes it's from this
government and if there was an outside
threat yeah it looks like he's about to
come out with like a bomb strapped to
his chest walk into like an elementary
school
in the 80s running the mujahideen war
whose families military bases over in
Saudi Arabia
man lady
here he is everybody Hit the Floor I've
been called a liar I've been silenced on
virtually every platform created don't
come to work today my life has been
threatened
he's stuck to have this other they're
showing here he would be fine and just
like stayed with that like Mass
surveillance Attack Helicopters black
helicopters right and like didn't extend
it into like Sandy Hook survivors or
crisis actors you know what I mean but
you always got to ramp it up you gotta
ramp up the narrative the black the
black
you know the black helicopters oh that's
fun it's silly it's fun you know what I
mean you know they're making the
freaking frogs gay like it's true well
they're not making them gay they're
making them trans but still well you
know difference at the end of the day
but I survived
and that's why I'm joining the club oh
God Jesus embarrassing to see that yeah
there he is look at the red light
shining on that beautiful Dome my
friends it's embarrassing to see a
legend fall so far from Grace yeah I
agree I mean Alex Jones joining the mug
Club is a is a bottom frankly I never
predicted for him yeah
but at least you're still here Alex
Jones everybody
oh God
Jack dude I love him dude he's a
Beefcake bro he is he is a hamburger you
could make like a [__] a whole
you can make like a whole dinner from
his body of dinner I don't know what I
don't know what it is I mean he has
talked about cannibalizing his neighbors
before yeah
my hug
over an open flame
you know what I mean
people say they like Dad bods like
that's a real dad bod right there that
don't like Dad yeah that's the divorce
dad Bond when I when people say they
like Dad bods don't get excited guys
you're not [__] ready for this kind
of dad ball this is some real daddy let
me show you what a real dad bod looks
like he he is look at this full bear
mode hold on hold on let me look here
this this is what comes up when I search
Dad bod oh yeah dude yeah wow well
embarrassing
love 12 body fat maximum body fat
maximum wow that's me dad
you want to see what's a real dad bod
here this is a dad bod yes nobody likes
I mean no offense to Seth Rogen he's you
know
speaking of sexy in their own right
Juicy uh new Jonah Hill dude he's skinny
he lost a lot of weight he's like skinny
as you can be as a person can be yeah
it's kind of crazy
he really uh I mean [__] he did my man's
been hitting that ozembic dude he is you
think so I mean yeah I mean he did lose
a lot of weight before the ozempic he's
been losing weight steadily for a long
time first of all before the Olympic for
Hollywood Olympic has been a constant
for really they've been doing it for a
long time how long
for years
there's like I I I know from uh some of
the people I I train with that like
people have been
experimenting with those epic for a
minute I saw this and I didn't even
recognize him at first yeah good for I
mean listen I know that
he's a piece of [__] and all that but
those are good yeah the sexy sexy he's
even tucked in that's like the ultimate
yeah Skinny Move I I gotta tell you I
gotta tell you yeah
decent amount of uh pushback on the Seth
Rogen not being hot I said he's hot in
his own right okay I understand that
women I understand that he's sexy in his
own right right but if you do a poll of
like what body is hot
I'm telling you guys and don't [__]
argue with me
they're gonna argue with you you're
gonna you're gonna pick they're gonna I
don't know man I feel like manipulation
station you got gas lighting your your
significant other maybe gives you a good
ass bod like that just rethinking my uh
my Jonah Hill interpretation here I need
to go home and uh
psychologically abuse my wife yeah get
in there him
I mean
the irony is if you behave like that the
right wing would love you more they'd be
like oh Ethan is finally seeing the
light
he's so based in place I mean okay this
is my body type so listen I'm not I'm
not even like
I'm not even angry that you're saying I
just don't believe yeah just just accept
the compliment yeah skinny man good uh
so we if we have forgiven him dad that's
why everybody thirst traps for me and
not Hassan right because you all love
Dad bods yeah well they do throw strap
also um it's ironic that you're saying
this in this community like anywhere
else maybe but like in this community
they do unironically third straps so
like it's a meme
what what did I type dad bad oh God that
bad that bad
all right whatever let's move on oh yeah
yeah we got we got it we got it anyway
skinny skinny
there he is there he is thank you you're
giving like Santa Claus alcoholic down
bad yeah well Mrs Claus left me I've
been hitting the liquor pretty hard I've
been hitting the eggnog a little too
hard Miss Claus took the kids and the
prisons I took my elves took my little
elves they were my little helpers those
little [__] went out with Mick claws
I kept trying to put my dick on their
shoulders they were too low to the
ground couldn't do it so now with
Stephen Crowder's help I could do he'll
put his dick on my shoulder put my dick
on his uh uh Brian Cowan you're gonna be
my elf now [__] real Macho [__]
everybody tuning in I think everybody
chewing right now but I want to be
deadly serious here I've not been this
excited ever
[Applause]
wow so I've known Stephen for more than
10 years used to you know beg him to
call him my show always a really busy
man and he's a bit popper forever mad
but we kind of knew each other but as
soon as I got the platformed he saw as a
threat he said I want you on immediately
after when everybody else was running
away including my friends he was like no
yeah because he saw clout because you
were still like a known entity yeah
everybody was riding for him yeah Joe
Rogan had you on too exactly yeah
exactly like is that a Rolex he's
wearing because we're gonna have to talk
about yeah we're gonna put a lean on
that bad boy what's happening there
liquidation station I wouldn't be
wearing that on camera because they're
gonna come for that role he's out of a
decent amount of time now
what's up
Dan
okay well we've almost been going for
two hours
oh yeah I didn't even realize that so I
know some flies when you're having fun
that's right
oh my God wait this one is
is this one more I'm not gonna analyze
his body you know what I mean whatever
it's not the vibe
but he looks good
looks like Rumpelstiltskin he's he's
giving um
Castaway
yeah I don't know what happened there he
passed away he looks like he would steal
someone and put them in a tower
he looks like he would tell his
girlfriend not to Surf with other men
right he's giving that wait what did you
say Dan
steal somebody and put them in a tower
like Rumpelstiltskin style oh okay wow
you thought he was being anti-semitic I
was just trying to understand the
Rumpelstiltskin anti-semitic Trope but
he stole a base I don't know anything
about it yeah
spin me gold [__] Rumble foreskin
actually he's for sure anti-semitic
Trope wow but he stole the baby not a
grown ass we got a lot we got a lot of
learning to do today
he stole the foreskin Rumple foreskin
okay wait let me ask chat you BT if it's
anti-semitic oh my Lord oh here we go
[__] this chat
you guys are just hating for no [__]
don't knock yourself Ethan yeah let me
take this off screen why why can't we
talk about the news oh god perogos dude
this isn't about anti-Semitism it's
about cancel culture
now I'm not saying Hitler was a good guy
nope
but but I kinda Wanna Know
why yes girl sing it are you not logged
into it no I don't know why it always
logs out I I the password's some long
password I can ask for you if you would
like ask if you ask Chad GPD what your
password is
see if you got it he does uh you can ask
is Rumpelstiltskin a anti-semitic story
archetype yeah Story character
anti-semitic character
hey hey hey spin me some gold [__] or
I'm stealing your child uh also what do
you look like I'm disapproving of what
he's he's this guy is saying here
chapter gbt saying it's not it's been a
hell that was published by the brothers
Grim in 1812 there's no evidence to
suggest that the story itself is
explicit it's Brothers Grimm dude
immediately it's more it's even more
[__] up than anti-Semitism okay
Rumple still skin let's see what he
looked like let's see what's his graph
you know the modern rendition is going
to be like
the way they portrayed him in Shrek come
on oh for real let me try it right there
right there is that at CPU one how is
that not the one
oh I see
that's [__] up actually but
um I don't see this guy looking Jew it
looks more Irish he like he's like he's
like hey he's saying this contract and I
don't know he's a banker yeah that is so
funny what's next uh
you're going to tell me this guy's not
an anti-semitic archetype yeah that one
oh Gargamel yeah Gargamel
I don't think anyone's look at that boy
is this French yeah it's French oh it's
definitely anti-semitis oh yeah 100 this
is a ripped like straight from Nazi
propaganda poster oh yeah 100 The Smurfs
Belgian or French
and Harry Potter yeah the little uh oh
yeah those those are uh
yeah a lot of a lot of a lot of
antisemitic well to be fair to the ears
are pretty you know
to be
oh no I was gonna say to be fair like
anti-Semitism is like like second nature
so yeah they don't even they don't even
think about it they're just like yeah
what do you mean this is
your man so
um gosh we have very little time left
let's see uh there's all those um uh
Trump videos yeah I'd love to watch
those which part of those in so you can
uh at the top of the show oh top of the
show okay great so let's see um oh this
is good the sweating videos yeah yeah
yeah we love these
he is fighting for his life out there
it's about 110 degrees of this room nice
job with the air conditioning yeah
[Applause]
you know what the Press will say you
know they'll say Trump didn't look well
you don't though I I how dare you but it
looks great it's the combination of like
the concealer the fake Tanner
it's all coming together
to make him look like a cadaver for an
open he's he's glistening like a like a
Glizzy he looks like a really crispy
piece of like KFC man right like you
feel that skin off
extremely wet he looks like 104 or five
degrees in Israel but we're okay with it
right he looks like a piece of meat that
you leave in a buffet under those like
heat lamps
he looks like rotisserie chicken that
you left under the heat lamp for too
long everyone's loving that though
[Applause]
he's the man dude
yeah he was did you see the the Chris
Christie one is that in here yep is that
in the docket plan next one that's so
good that's such good Trump moment here
he's coming after Chris Christie who is
of course uh obese it's pretty funny
because like so is Trump right yeah
there is nothing more American than
being a fat guy calling another slightly
fatter guy incredibly fat that is like
the most American thing you can do
it's my favorite oh God who's good
no no Christy's he's eating right now he
can't be bothered
just so like playground this man is like
80 almost
and running for president supposed to
have some dignity
sir please do not call him a fat pig
that's very difficult
oh see I'm trying to be nice Don't Call
Him a fat man I'm trying to be nice he
can't do that he's so awesome so now
because you're not allowed to do that
and therefore We're not gonna do it okay
yeah you're not allowed to do it
liberals won't let me do it that can you
pull Don't Call Him a fat pig
it's so good it's so good I'm a fat pig
here's another one man Chad said he's
white lizzo
yeah that's perfect
I wonder if he takes his uh I'm sealed
to the uh strip club
shoot Diet Cokes out of their vagina or
something
morning consult that just came out I
wanted to see because you know every
time you get indicted how to check the
polls because
one more indictment that I think this
election's over
[Applause]
dude I am so stoked this is the Georgia
one that's gonna happen in the end of
this week or by next week at least uh
that one is a state court which means
that yeah they could televise it they
already have said that they are going to
per block them and mug shot him oh I
didn't know that we're gonna get it oh
boy we're gonna get a mug shot yeah
finally man finally hopefully [__] in
New York because New York was State
Chargers too but they push you down they
didn't yeah the mug shot yeah Alvin
Bragg he's a coward he's a total he
wouldn't give me a mug shot one more
indictment folks he's worried
it is 104 in the compound to be fair
out here and or no in his where he's
still speaking no no no
for Israel it's definitely not 104 in
here oh yeah people don't realize but we
have a really Advanced AI filter that
cleans you guys up yeah this is what
we're seeing right now in here it's hot
yeah we're lit the [__] up hot day right
here with the air conditioning
this is a third this becomes a third
world country the latest morning console
poll and yeah yeah yeah morning consult
that just came out I wanted to see
because you just started
a nice little Loop there one more
indictment okay oh okay there it is and
then there's one more here uh
a whole nother bit about the shower
sucking we love that for him remember
this was like a big thing water pressure
it was it was the showers and he would
also always [__] about how he he would
clog toilets constantly the toilets
don't flush toilets aren't what they
used to be I have to flush 10 times Mr
President
not the most flattering image you know
little things like you think you know
you buy a sink and no water comes out
because they have so related on the
water even if you're in a state where
water comes out of Heaven all day long
is this something that's happening it
doesn't happen to me and we live in
California like the toilet thing he's
right on
um but I I don't know if that's a thing
like do they have water Regulators that
are like forcing you to have less water
I think so in some cities on shower
heads I know they put it in there I
think that's like self-selected though
you you opt into they're like mandated
yeah I believe there is some type of
thing in California because when I buy a
shower head I take the little regulator
out oh you don't know
hit the button hit the button hit the
button
go over here Gavin you're awesome I had
to like order it from like Ohio or some
[__] like that yo bro he's getting
illegal shower heads what's happening
he's a third world country
don't bring that Contraband into myself
he's right then yeah the suds so many
suds
uh when you take a shower I like to have
you know I have this gorgeous head of
hair oh yeah God he's so good when I
take a shower I want water to pour down
on me when you go into these new homes
with showers the water drips down slowly
and slowly you'd have such beautiful
Suds a lot of money Procter and gambling
money shall we say is good probably cost
them cost them about two cents and they
sell it for ten dollars but [__] it's
so capitalist scum it's so good he just
like he just drops that in there for no
reason and it's awesome like you're like
yeah you're right yeah you know what you
do you just stay in the shower about 10
times longer than you would have it's
the same you probably use more water I
broke all that up
I broke all that up you did it yeah I
can't waffle stop blanket you stupid man
when I [__] it just sticks in the drain
big massive dumps that's a Joe Biden
yeah I could see Joe Biden sitting in
the shower accidentally yeah or per at a
certain point you know accidental
purposely the line gets blurred all
right thank you uh everybody
this has been another leftovers you're
welcome
tomorrow's episode is going to be better
Yeah well yeah always promises it won't
be hard to top this one too yeah
what uh how you doing uh you've got a
you got a nice weekend coming up
uh yeah I might be uh talking to the
showrunner of the uh new Netflix
one-piece adaptation coming out
obviously we won't be talking about that
because it's the violation uh could be a
Bible we love one piece on this show
yeah especially the Netflix adaptation
[Music]
thank you
happening
[Music]
I'm gonna eat here I hit the button what
is wait really wait what wait did you
phrase it yes yes what's wrong
I'll tell you after the show did I cut
it I don't know well I okay
should we end oh
what what okay I'm not saying anything
what just happened I don't know
God damn
I think all that God anyway looking
forward to talking to the show runner of
uh
anyway bye everybody
[Music]